My name is Mithvetov!
I'm really sweaty!
And I really love Metal Gear!
So, listen to me sing Metal Gear songs!
Woohoo!
Petals of white cover fields, flowing in grieving tears.
And all the hearts, once new, old and shattered now.
Love can kill, love will die, give me wings to fly.
Fleeing this world so cold, I just wonder why.
Dramatic zoom!
Cold as the dark, now my words are frosted with every breath.
Still the hate burns wild, growing inside this heart.
When the wind changes course, when the stars align.
I will reach out to you, and leave this all behind.
When heavens divide.
I'm...
Um...
I don't know what else to say.
I'm really nervous.
Um...
Uh...
Metal...
Metal Gear?
Um...
I really...
Uh...
Thank you guys!
I hope you guys have been enjoying the karaoke relay so far!
Everybody sounded great!
Um...
Uh...
And...
I hope you...
There's still lots of people left!
So...
Have lots of fun today!
Woohoo!
When heavens divide.
I will see.
The choices within me.
In my hands.
How can we ever protect?
And fight with our tiny souls?
Let me shine.
Like the sun.
Through the doubts and fear.
Do you feel the storm approach?
As the end draws near.
When heavens divide.
Time will come.
To softly lay.
Me down.
Then I can see a face.
That I long to see.
And for you.
Only you I would give anything.
Leaving a trace.
For love to find a way.
When heavens divide.
Time will come.
I'm gonna have to speed run through these songs, so I won't have much time to talk, but I'm a yapper!
Let's go!
I will dive into the fire Spilling the blood of my desire The very last time My name scorched into the sky When heavens divide I will see the choices within my hands How can we ever protect and fight with our tiny souls?
Let me shine Like the sun Through the doubts and fear Do you feel the storm approach As the end draws near?
When heavens divide Time will come to softly lay me down Then I can see a face That I long to see And for you Only you I would give anything Leaving a trace For love to find a way When heavens divide Anything
Leaving a trace For love to find a way
When heaven's divine...
Hold on.
I have to transition.
One second.
Give me a second.
Oh my gosh.
Wait.
All my stuff is all over the place.
Hold on.
Oh my gosh.
Go away.
Go to this.
Hold on.
One second.
Okay.
I'm going to sing the next song.
I'm nervous.
Where is my next song?
Oh, here it is.
Okay.
Oh gosh.
This song is so hard.
I'm so nervous.
Oh my gosh.
Okay.
Blind in the deepest night.
Reaching out, grasping for fleeting memory.
All these thoughts.
Keep piercing this broken mind.
I fall.
But I'm still standing.
Motionless.
Far.
In the distance.
There is light.
A light that burns these scars of old.
All this pain.
Reminds me of what I am.
I'll live.
I'll become all I need to be.
Whoa.
Words that kill.
Except I'm not.
I'm actually a ghost.
It's so funny.
But I never die, because I'm a ghost.
I mean, I'm already dead.
It's like undead, but not really undead, because I'm not a zombie, I'm a ghost.
What do I really count as?
Where do I fall under?
I'm having an existential crisis in the middle of this song, oh my gosh.
Anyway, okay.
Let's just keep going, right?
Pride feeds their blackened hearts And the thirst must be quenched to fuel hypocrisy Cleansing flames is the only way to repent Renounce what made you words that kill Would you speak them to me?
With your breath so still It makes me believe This part is so hard.
The sins never die Can't wash this blood off our hands Let the world fear us all It's just means to an end Our salvation lies
Beyond the truth Let me suffer now
In my heart I just know that there's no way to light up the dark In his eyes
The next song, I've never sung before on stream, so I'm very nervous about it.
I'm nervous about all these, but anyway, I'm going to try and sync it to the best ability that I can.
Here we go.
Oh, where's my song?
There it is.
Here it is.
A little pause... and we are back.
A little pause...
and we are back.
A little
pause...
and we are back.
Okay, one more song!
One more song left and then I'll transfer you over to the next person.
If you don't know anything about Metal Gear, I hope that you still enjoyed the songs.
It's a great series, I really promise you.
Can I please spread the good word of Metal Gear, right?
Anyway, my last song may be a song that, maybe even if you don't know Metal Gear, you might know this one because it is the Metal Gear song, perhaps.
But yeah, my final song and then I'll pass you over.
Thank you guys for listening and...
Oh my gosh, hold on.
Let me get it up.
Let me get it ready.
What
a thrill With darkness and silence through the night What a thrill I'm searching and I'll melt into you What a fear in my heart But you're so supreme I give my life Not for honor, but for you Saiki da!
In my time There'll be no one else
It's the way I fly to you I'm still in a dream Snake it up
Someday you go through the rain
A little pause... and we are back.
A little pause... and
we are back.
There'll be no one else...
Oh my god, my voice is cracking.
Crime is the way I fly to you.
I'm still in a dream, Snake Eater.
This is the outro.
I forgot.
I was like, yes, this is the outro.
I was like, wait.
Thank you guys!
Thank you!
Have fun with the rest of the karaoke.
And I'll see you guys later.
Bye bye!
What if we just have this playing as the outro instead?
Nana, bub,
it's time to redirect.
Nana, bub, it's time to redirect.
Perfect.
Oh, it's gone.
Okay, never mind.
You know what?
Bye!